whether emptying the streets of Times
Square wrecking state-of-the-art sports
cars for fun or blowing up real military
ships
the movies on this list have invested
heavily in solitary scenes lasting mere
minutes these sequences are the most
expensive movie scenes ever filmed
Vanilla Sky sets the tone of surreal
reality question and confusion from the
opening scene the perfectly groomed gray
hair plucking playboy millionaire David
Ames wakes as Radiohead's everything in
its right place
aptly Lyra sizes his life immaculate
flawless perfected yet as David drives
his vintage Ferrari through the streets
of New York the first cracks in this
illusion appear he drives to Times
Square the crossroads of the world with
approximately 330,000 daily passers-by
it's completely empty not even the
faintest hint of the usual hustle and
bustle David wakes abruptly it was all a
dream a false awakening interpreted by
his therapist as a metaphor well I
suppose the empty Street meant
loneliness you're a shrink you got to do
better than that
at only 30 seconds of screen time the
scene provides a fundamental function in
the narrative questioning the nature of
reality and our relationship to dreams
surprisingly no CGI was used instead
director Cameron Crowe struck a deal
with the NYPD to close off the area
between 5:00 a.m. and 8:00 a.m. on a
Sunday in November 2000 the result was a
spectacular sequence with a spectacular
price tag over 1 million dollars for 30
seconds of footage was it worth it
absolutely combining Cruz's enigmatic
star power with the desolate backdrop
helps create a poignant scene lacking in
the 1997 spanish-language original open
your eyes in I am Legend Will Smith
roams the post-apocalyptic streets of
New York City as dr. Robert Neville of I
Rolla gist attempting to find a cure for
the zombie producing Crippen virus to
create the feeling of desperate
isolation the film like Vanilla Sky has
empty streets to match Warner Brothers
empty wallets however a substantial
chunk of its 150 million dollar budget
was allocated to a much more populated
scene capturing Neville's tragic
separation from his wife and child in
flashbacks the audience sees that
New York City was evacuated and placed
under quarantine during the outbreak in
a race against time
nevels family boards a helicopter to
escape then comes a breathtaking moment
of tragedy the military bombs the
Brooklyn Bridge amidst the chaos the
blazing bridge collapses into the water
below and nevels family tragically dies
in the ensuing accident a fair share of
digital magic was used to capture the
missiles impact still the surrounding
evacuation was shot on location across
six nights requiring the cooperation of
1,000 extras 14 different government
agencies and expansive lighting rig and
a crew of 250 increased bureaucracy post
9/11 made acquiring the green light on
the project a task that cost a cool five
million dollars think of James Bond and
what's the first thing that comes to
mind aside from a cat stroking evil
genius cool gadgets and Bond girls the
answer is probably luxurious cars after
all what would double-oh-seven be
without an Aston Martin db5 for company
a car featured in seven different
installments snazzy automobiles are
largely part of the series mythology and
Spectre continued that tradition by
placing Daniel Craig in the front seat
of the stylish aston martin db10 a car
produced exclusively for the 2015 film
illustrative of the multi-millions
hollywood has to play with 32 million
dollars of spectres rumored 300 million
to three hundred and fifty million
dollar budget was spent destroying cars
the biggest expenditure came from
totaling seven of the ten after
mentioned DB tens a fact that will no
doubt cause car enthusiasts to shed a
tear
chief stunt coordinator Gary Powell told
the Daily Mail in Rome we wrecked
millions of pounds worth the db10 sped
through the narrow streets of the
Vatican at top speeds of 110 miles per
hour in a cat-and-mouse chase with a
henchman in a Jaguar CX 75 a set amount
for this singular scene hasn't been
confirmed but the number of destroyed DB
tens were quote shot one entire night
for four seconds of film making its cost
per footage ratio astronomically high
smashing DB tends to smithereens is
frugal when compared to Bryan Singer's
Superman Returns resurrecting kal-el on
nearly two decades after Superman for
the quest for peace one particular scene
depicted Superman returning to Krypton
abstract atmospheric and visually
striking the CGI heavy sequence is
intriguing channeling elements of
thoughtful slow-paced sci-fi however
that tone was such a stark contrast to
the rest of the film a fun superhero
movie that Warner Brothers chose to cut
it out of the final cut it was a bold
decision not least from a financial
perspective creating Superman's
homeworld cost an estimated 10 million
dollars making it one of the most
expensive scenes in history and most
likely the costliest deleted scene ever
Superman Returns earned favorable
reviews although it failed to capture
the imagination of audiences illustrated
by an underwhelming worldwide box office
of 391 million dollars maybe that
Krypton scene would have helped four
years after neo swallowed the red pill
and unveiled the true nature of reality
in the Matrix the philosophical
cyberpunk sensation returned in 2003
with the second installment in the
trilogy this time the Wachowskis had
over doubled a budget which it's safe to
say they spent wisely ignoring the adage
don't play with traffic the duo rejected
digital effects and instead constructed
a fake freeway at a decommissioned Naval
Base in Alameda California you always
told me to stay off the freeway
that's true stretching a mile-and-a-half
the set was the backdrop for reloaded
white-knuckle chase between Morpheus
Trinity the twins and a host of agents
surprisingly the Wachowskis also opted
for real-life stunts Trinity actress
Carrie and moss who overcame a quote
major fear of motorcycle shooting the
scene told IGN they needed to have the
best stunt people in the world it was
dangerous you could really feel that
every day you went out there the final
result is 20 minutes of mind-blowing
physics defying carnage and one of the
most memorable car chases in cinematic
history as for the total cost that had
the blue pill treatment never to be
revealed publicly however the freeway
alone cost two point five million
dollars throw in over 100 destroyed cars
practical effects and CGI and a
significant percentage of the 150
million dollar budget was likely spent
on this single sequence the Second World
War was one of the deadliest conflicts
in history with casualties estimated to
be over 56 million one of the most
bone-chilling unfathomably brutal
battles the d-day landing was also the
largest seaborne invasion in history
those who weren't there will never truly
know what it was like but Steven
Spielberg's acclaimed portrayal in 1998
Saving Private Ryan offers some insight
most notable is its depiction of the
Allies arrival on Omaha Beach a tense
sequence Empire magazine ranked as the
quote greatest battle in cinema an
unforgettable opening 25 minutes to pick
Tom Hanks captain Miller facing
impossible odds marching through
blood-soaked sand outmaneuvering
explosions and dodging bullets leading
the way for the Allies eventual victory
at the German occupied shore its
filmmaking at its finest realistic
immersive heartbreaking and it earned
Spielberg the Oscar for Best Director
shot over the course of four weeks a
cast of 750 captured the horror of that
fateful day on June 6 1944 unable to
shoot at Omaha Beach
Spielberg shot on location on the east
coast of Ireland at cura close strand
with minimal direction in the original
script most shots were quote
spur-of-the-moment and unplanned ahead
of time
Spielberg told DGA quarterly of the
approach it helped make things a little
more chaotic and unpredictable
considering the magnitude of the scene
and its lasting cultural impact it's 12
million dollar budget might have been a
good deal Michael Bay is renowned
four larger-than-life spectacles
brimming with huge explosions and
bombtastic set-pieces epitomized by his
live-action Transformers franchise
clearly there's a thirst for big robots
that turn into things with the series
earning a total worldwide box office of
four point four eight billion dollars
the last night was the most poorly
reviewed in the series receiving a
measly 15% on Rotten Tomatoes
but that wasn't due to a lack of
investment its budget was a whopping 217
million dollars with a large chunk of
that spent on location for one
particular scene as previous
transformers installment age of
extinction concluded in a junkyard
producers were keen to maintain
continuity Phoenix film commissioner
Phil Brad stock wryly remarked to
phoenix Business Journal the movies art
director was probably just doing a
google image search for a junkyard and
they came across this junkyard just
north of Deer Valley Airport Arizona's
authorities won't be complaining about
the fortuitous Google Image Search
though it led to a hefty investment in
the area
in a rare detailed insight Brad stock
revealed that over the 10 day shoot
producers hired 40 locals to work behind
the scenes as well as 50 local vendors
and 3,000 cumulative Hotel nights two
months on location equated to an
investment of fifteen million dollars
before factoring in CGI and other cost
increasing factors Marlon Brando was
widely regarded as one of the finest
actors of his generation if not any
generation when he won his second
Academy Award for his captivating
portrayal of Don Corleone in 1972 s The
Godfather that film was also a
blockbuster and if the producers of the
first big-budget Superman movie wanted
to secure the great Brando to play
Superman's father jor-el they were
certainly going to have to dig deep and
pay up I'm gonna make him an awfully go
with you Brando ultimately appears in
1978 Superman the movie for about ten
minutes out of the film's 143 minute
running time and yet he received top
billing over both Academy Award winner
Gene Hackman who played Lex Luthor and
relative newcomer Christopher Reeve who
actually portrayed the lead character in
addition to an appearance fee of 3.7
million dollars Brando was also
contractually obligated to take home 12%
of the film's profits
the former Godfather's take was 19
million dollars in 2020 dollars that's a
seventy-five million dollars and this
doesn't even count the expensive-looking
Krypton sets that filmmakers had to
build for Brando's brief scenes it's
almost impossible to imagine the
magnitude of the production behind Ben
Hur the 1959 adaptation of Lew Wallace's
novel and remake of the 1925 silent film
of the same name is memorable for its
extravagance a stunning 9 minute chariot
race is the crux of Wallace's story and
William Wyler's feature gravitates
around the same centerpiece enduring
acclaim is a deserving accomplishment
following five years of preparation the
production was tireless and demanding
including 300 sets covering 140 acres 9
sound stages and thousands of extras set
at Cinecitta Studios in Italy it was the
largest film set of its era the arena
alone set in the fictional ancient city
Antioch was built by a construction team
of 750 workers created to capture the
race between Judah ben-hur and masala
shot over 10 weeks the singular scene
cost four million dollars in today's
money that's over thirty four million
dollars or around three point seven
million dollars for each minute of
footage metro-goldwyn-mayer wanted the
experience to lure audiences into
theaters though and it worked
to this day Ben Hur is one of the
highest-grossing films ever
proving sometimes that hefty investments
pay off in 2001 director Michael Bay at
the time best known for Armageddon took
his penchant for big explosions and
dazzling effects shots and applied them
to a story set against the backdrop of
actual historical events the result
Pearl Harbor an epic action movie that
takes place primarily during events
leading up to the 1941 Japanese military
bombing of the US base in Hawaii they
went all out to realistically and
graphically depict the bombing of Pearl
Harbor one of the most famous and
destructive acts in American history and
this is no computer-generated mayhem and
bloodshed they used practical effects
and a lot of them the crew employed the
use of 700 sticks of dynamite and 4,000
gallons of gasoline to properly blow up
six inactive ships from the Navy it took
around a month to set everything up and
the director certainly didn't want to
miss anything
so he set up 12 cameras to film it all
in all this one scene in Pearl Harbor
cost approximate
five point five million dollars check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]